[Music]
oh yes don't ask but I'll get the fish
where's choco choco chop for the BBQ no
no no no no you kidding okay we do me a
favor can you fill it that first son is
dead no it's dead come on everyone
forgot the charcoal looks like dad's got
a plan it can't be sushi garlic
how are we gonna cook it watch and learn
where's mummy thanks daddy one piece of
bass dad puts on the fish billets and
some lemons now we have to wrap it
really tight so no juice falls out
we go to cook it let me show you how
your genius daddy is gonna cook it
follow me ladies let's go I think that's
gone mad
can you flip the litter please there now
what open the oven door oh I seriously
think you might have lost it this time
it's going inside on the engine you rest
that beautiful bass on there what'd we
do last Holi close the other door gas
mark 5 point 6 liter engine let's go
cook some bass yes my best Mel's
delicious cooking food on your parents
car without their knowing well dad is
opening a maniac trying to cook the fish
on the car engine as he drives along
hello I'm making my squishiest squashes
we messy a salad ever at least we'll
have a tasty salad for lunch this recipe
is all about tomatoes to make it super
colorful I'm using two different types
of tomatoes yellow and red wow these are
very juicy put this in my bowl add in
chopped cucumber and I scooped out the
seedy bits in the middle and then
chopped red onion some of this Bazo
the smells really good perfect the wind
doesn't throw away my salad because if
that's fish we're not gonna have a lot
to eat your salads brilliant be using up
your snail bread old crusty herb bread
is the best bread you just rip it up
into pieces and put it in next chunks of
mozzarella
I love mozzarella and finally the
dressing and roughly eight tablespoons
of the olive oil 3 tablespoons of red
wine vinegar and then some garlic whisk
it all around and simply add in the
dressing and then my favorite bit the
squishy-squashy messy part now I've got
very messy hands and now I'm gonna get a
photo for my blog from a real chef like
me to madcap chef like dad this is the
secret behind slow speed up at 35
[Music]
delicious he is confident that's for
sure we're talking baby
leave the other non please get some food
there's no way that fish will barbecue
in the car last time you took to see
bass on a top of an engine and never
this is the first I don't think that's
car be queuing is going to work but if
it goes your role at least we'll have my
watermelon pizza - okay it's not a real
pizza it's a super delicious pudding and
just like pizza you can top it with
whatever you won for a big pizza you
need a big watermelon so I'm just gonna
cut it in half and then make a thick
slice great look at that just like a
pizza base then I'm gonna add on my
toppings the red watermelon looks like
tomato sauce then the Apple - like
artichoke next add grapes look at that
in it like olives Kiwi it's got lots of
good fruits on here and to make it look
really authentic time for the mozzarella
just joking is only coconut and then
this is my super sauce tangy syrup lime
juice sugar and water mixed together
that should be enough on the plate and
this is my pizza slice for later I'm
gonna take some pictures from my blog
they're back do the cul BQ worked better
be cooked I'm so excited I'm so hungry
please
oh no cold no it's hot I'm gonna carry
this to the table
gently please okay gently very gently
please my open sea bass daddy's about to
burst he's so excited looks good if all
else fails he's only gone and done it no
my goodness look at that I mean
seriously come on right Holly the bass
please really yummy yes that is pretty
impressive Matilda I doubted you at
first but how does it taste really good
I'm a little bit amazed at how sweet and
delicious and soft it is all right dad
what about the salad sounds delicious
obviously goes well with the dishes bass
I hate to admit it but that was a genius
bit of cooking from dad hey guys now for
dessert there's a watermelon pizza very
very very pretty young look at that hmm
tell us good job thank you thank you did
you enjoy day out I think it's fair
enough to say Holly and I we've been
surprised by how much we did enjoy the
fishing